but first another day another pathetic
Democrat clown show on Capitol Hill now
remember the party of abortion on demand
and now infanticide cares more about the
children than you heartless soulless
Republicans do you not care
is it because these children don't look
like children that are around you have
you ever held a deceased child in your
arms first of all your comments are
disgusting I've served my country for 34
years and yes I held a five-year-old boy
in my arms that in fact that tractor
trailer I knelt down beside him and said
a prayer for him because I knew what his
last 30 minutes his life were like and I
had a five-year-old son at the time if
you just sit there and insult my
integrity it might love my country and
for the Emperor children that's why this
whole thing needs to be fixed I wanted
to give him a standing ovation all day
long just for that moment but there are
a lot of them and what Tom Holman is
rightfully pointing out is that the
congressman up there AOC and all of her
ilk refused to accept this crazy concept
known as the rule of law so you are the
author of the family separation policy
I'm not the author of this memo you're
not the author but you sign the memo yes
you recommend a family separation I
recommend a zero tolerance which
includes family separation the same as
is whatever you a citizen parent gets
arrested when they're with a child if I
get arrested for DUI and I have a young
child in a car I will be separated to
respect legal asylees are not charged
with any crime when you're in the
country illegally this violation eight
United States Code 1325 seeking asylum
is legal if you want to seek asylum to
go through the port of entry do the
legal way the Attorney General the
United States has made that clear okay
whoops today's hearing was convened by
the House Oversight Committee whose
members included three of the four
progressive it girls
now conjuring up emotion and passion
usually reserved for border crossers
gaming our immigration laws they read
from the dog-eared script that demon
is Border Patrol and ice and forgets
about duly passed laws by our
legislature forget about those but at a
certain point former acting ice director
Tom Holman had had just about enough as
a 34-year veteran law enforcement is
shocking shocking to see the constant
attacks against those that leave the
safety and security of their homes every
day put on a Kevlar vest and put a gun
in her hip and risk her own safety
defend this nation so you have to wake
up every day and see news reports and
commas from replicas comments from
representatives in Congress that they're
Nazis white supremists that the operate
concentration camps that didn't only
abused women and children ice agents and
Borba troll agents are mom and dad's too
they have children what they see every
day in this unprecedented surge of
children families affects them deeply
and emotionally as any of those who
easily attacked the men and women of the
Borbon show ice you ever walked up to
one and thank one for serving their
nation yet we ever had to consult a
small child or spouse or a fallen
officer I have too many times game set
match the only borders the new and
radicalized Democratic Party believes in
now are those around maybe abortion
clinics keeping sidewalk counselors away
from vulnerable women
that's a border they'll enforce but what
if the Democrats ever expressed a smidge
even a little bit of empathy toward the
thousands of victims of crimes or DUIs
committed by illegal immigrants such as
Cory Cottrill who last month was killed
when an illegal who had been ordered
deported drove drunk and ran him over
his family including two young daughters
are separated from him forever not for
just a few weeks or a few a few months
so it's AOC or any well known elected
Democrat shed one tear for these types
of tragedies ever not that I've seen
instead they would rather paint America
as a gulag for immigrants who are all
good and deserving
despite the laws that they do violate
and court orders that they brazenly
ignore our
government at the hands of this
administration has exhibited an
incompetent and cruelty that has created
a human rights crisis in our own country
they've now gone from denying that there
is a crisis to accusing those working to
stop it our border agents of actually
creating a culture of cruelty there is
no need for us to arrest innocent people
and treat them no differently than
criminals when they are pursuing their
basic human rights calling these Ashe
with style concentration camps
that doesn't help solve the problem now
to love these Democrats America
especially when it's being led by Donald
Trump is broken and illegitimate the
whole country so the laws that Democrats
don't like they too are illegitimate
joining me now is congressman Sean Duffy
former NYPD Commissioner Bernie Kerik an
immigration attorney good there Sanabria
it's great to have all of you with us
tonight going through let's start with
you this hearing was quite something
today we had Tom Holman who's he you
know actually put on a uniform and
served the country for three decades
he's really ticked off and I think
rightfully so about the broad brush
demonization of men and women Border
Patrol 50% of whom are Hispanic
Americans and your reaction to what he
said about that demonization well a
couple of things Laura number one I hear
mr. Holman talk about himself how he
feels
how the laws are being broken but I
don't hear him say anything about the
families I don't hear him say anything
about the children the mothers and we
recently heard of a child a baby Maria I
think it was her name that died in the
custody of immigration so I just would
like to see mr. Holman instead of
talking about the nightmares that he had
from the memories that he had when he
was serving and so you're upset that he
doesn't have enough emotion no he has
emotion but the emotions be directed
towards the children we're talking about
children we're not talking about adults
criminals and he continues to talk about
how he feels and he felt and how the ice
Patrol agents would feel about do you
think he is with if he's in a situation
with a crying child that he doesn't care
about that child I'm sure he cares but
he does care we all we all care about
all children are innocent
who were brought by people some of whom
were not their family members trafficked
across the border and used as pawns we
do care about them which is why we want
to asylum reform guards justifying
Bernie Kent Bernie Kerik when I was down
at Del Rio and Eagle Pass at the end of
April early May
what I saw was appalling here's some of
the video
people see the Border Patrol boat and
they jump with a pool toy or you know
blow up inner tube because they know our
Border Patrol are always going to pick
them up we're always gonna rescue them
that's what we do that's who we are
we don't purposely let people drown
other countries might do that we don't
do that
but today and listening to some of these
Democrats no no we don't pick them up
and in fact we want them to suffer
that's not what I saw down there what I
saw was we need to reform this system so
people are safe when they apply for
asylum and not endangering the lives of
children by bringing them thousands of
miles from their hometown your reaction
to this hearing today I think Tom Holman
should have walked out that's what I
personally think that's what I would
have done that you know the people that
make these comments these these members
of the House it's idiotic some of these
comments are just stupid the men and
women of the Board of Control and an ice
go out there every day and put their
lives on the line to protect this
country the people coming in to the
country illegally they are violating
federal law if you don't want those kids
separated from their families if you
don't want those kids taken away then
don't come into the country illegally
and if it's all about asylum apply for
asylum appropriately within the
guidelines of the law don't try to break
the law and come into the country and
then complain because of the outcome of
what happens next well as as we talked
about many times congressman Duffy that
trip up here is a bad trip people are
sleeping in fields on cement on benches
on floors occasionally someone will take
them in they'll sleep on a mat somewhere
but it's not like we're staying at the
Ritz
on the way up from Central America
that's not how it works someone during
trucks and buses so the idea that that
you know they come to the United States
and it's all terrible it's ridiculous
and it's bad it's overcrowded but come
on the asylum reform has to happen
because a lot of them do cross
congressman Duffy and when they cross
they are technically following the law
are they not so what Bernie just said is
you know it's not quite right because as
good they're said the they are pursuing
the legal process the legal process but
they should have screwed up they should
they should apply for asylum in the
first safe country they get to which is
Mexico and you know what burns my
backside I mean I I hear günther or
Alexandra Castillo Cortez or Democrats
you know shed tears for what's happening
inside of our detention centers which by
the way we should improve them but
you're right they came across the desert
with with Mexican drug cartels I would
love to have Gunther and Alexandra
Castillo cartels shut a tear for the
aims of moms will never hug their loved
ones any longer or the little girls or
women who are raped on the on the way
across the Mexican desert by drug
cartels or officers Singh who lost his
life on Christmas Day was murdered by a
illegal immigrant or Orono Gonzalez who
had his throat slit in the Mexican
desert by the drug cartel and his
ten-year-old son fake dead and was found
hugging his dad in the desert when you
said tear for those people and say let's
fix the problem close the loopholes and
if you're not gonna close the loopholes
Democrats and le's fought to spend the
4.6 billion dollars to the Border Patrol
so they can take care of the people that
are in the detention centers but when
Cortez doesn't vote for the money and
then cries about it give me a break this
is absolute insanity that's a shame Joe
yeah quickly then I gotta bring we got
to bring everyone to the big protest
tonight we got we got interesting report
that we got to get to I just don't
understand how Congress is Duff you
can't say that they come through a safe
country that is Mexico and they stay
make so I would like to see congressman
Duffy come through the through the
border and staying Mexico Easterners
coming to the United States this is a
country that protects refugees that
protects the those who cannot protect
themselves mr. Duffy you you cannot
compare the United States where Mexico
as a safe country that's just not right
you can see well I think we've said
echo is a safe place where if you're
going to get murdered or hurt in
Guatemala or El Salvador when you make
it to Mexico you can answer sir if I can
come to my point you make my point it's
a dangerous journey so don't sit and say
it's so horrific in the inner Detention
Center where you get a blanket and a
magnet we spent a day when they were
coming across the desert with drug
cartels you know sleeping on the sand
yeah we ought to bring everybody to
what's happening tonight their protests
all across the country
immigration protests and we sent Fox's
Leland Vitter to one outside the White
House watch what happened but there's
nobody being murdered on the southern
border yes children died how many
children have died so far six children
have died not six million people gasps
how is that the same it's the same you
separate children from their parents
okay what makes them a concentration
a number of people are consecrated
together
they should be treated with basic human
rights right well we know going through
that the basic human rights that we were
able to afford them was is limited by
how much resources were at the border I
was at this one of the smaller border
crossings Del Rio it was teeming and
these kids like this is all we have wait
what do they want us to leave let
children roam the streets just release
them so they're in there between a rock
and a hard place now the money's coming
in the kids are being I sent out but you
wouldn't have them just release them
into the streets we don't but the very
basics Gloria I mean we're talking about
children that are getting sick at this
distance some of them are sick when they
come and then they're then then we're
seeing a spread as we heard from dr.
drew all throughout different cities in
the United States of diseases we thought
we had eradicated had some died and just
be great just because one died we need
to stop it
Bernie close it out they can't the
concentration camp right yeah really
what do we make this Iran Rikers Island
for six years with a hundred and thirty
three thousand inmate admissions per
year I can tell you it's not an easy job
it's not an easy task with the numbers
that's coming into the country and the
numbers that they have to process we
either need more resources or they have
to stop it period and one we have to
stop at congressman Duffy this would
require Democrats and Republicans
working together that would actually be
solving the problem but there is no sign
is there that that's actually gonna
happen really quick it's not going to
happen because because Democrats like
this crisis as president Trump says you
can resolve it in 15 minutes close the
loopholes send money to - or detention
centers to make sure we have the
resources and this thing is all over but
Democrats are unwilling to do that so
the crisis continues and by the way
would it be nice if six months ago
they're going to recognize that we did M
equations on the board and sort of
coordinate a manufactured crisis that
was tell me on that we met we may not be
here today we're still doing that we're
still doing that guys great conversation
tonight we appreciate all your voices